[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
n
hello welcome back to gamespot's
coverage of e326 we're almost done with
the gauntlet of press conference this is
this is it Sony are taking us over the
finish line thank you so much for
joining us wherever you are watching on
Twitch on Gamespot on YouTube on
Facebook I think we are now and wherever
you are if you're in North America or if
you're in Europe Fair Play We Are into
the small hours but hopefully Sony will
make it worth it I'm very happy to be
joined by pet Brown my man T hi Alexa
Ray Korea hey how you all doing are you
ready 10 awesome I'm hyp seriously very
last year's Sony conference was pretty
good we got a bunch of fan aasal in the
form of shenmu and The Last Guardian and
Final Fantasy 7 and I'm looking at a
sheet of multiple games dozens and
dozens of games which we are going to
talk about now for the next 30 minutes
before uh they go live hopefully on time
there's been a lot of people late today
um but first of all I want to say half
of these games on this list Peter Brown
are for virtual reality yeah I mean
Sony's pushing right it's like October
is release state of psvr so I'm sure
they're going to focus on it a little
bit uh I just hope it's not the dominant
topic right their press conference why
not um well I think VR has a certain uh
you know the interest is spites and that
a lot of people were riding high off
that but that's kind of passed now and I
think if Sony really wants to do a good
job what they need to do is focus on
what they do traditionally which is
release good console games highlight VR
but don't bet all their you know their
money on that because you look at
Microsoft they had a bunch of good games
and new hardware M if Sony is just
showing off Hardware we've already seen
with games that only a fraction of the
audience is going to play because not
everyone's going to Shell out $400 for
the headset I'd say that's a probably
you know not a great move to make all
right let's stick with the hardware then
uh Playstation 4.5 the Neo zarine uh
Microsoft have already come out and you
know they showed off the slim but they
also said hey we got this thing coming
out in 18 months which we promis is four
times better um do you think it's the
right time for Sony to show off some of
the Neo do they have to like tip their
hat to it do you think we'll see a lot
of it how do you think it's going going
to go down I mean it's hard because
they've already come out and confirmed
that they're not going to talk about it
at right so if they do it'll be a really
pleasant surprise cuz it does mean that
they're making an active effort to try
and you know combat what Xbox has come
out with today but at the same time I
think like they're probably going to
stick by that just because they're a bit
conservative and safe in that regard but
that being said like if they promise
like we'll see more of the ne at like a
future show like Gamescom or TGs at
least that gives like a release date or
something down the line to expect son's
always an interesting one Alexa because
they go after Microsoft and so are able
to sort of like move the pieces
if needs be and we definitely saw that
back I guess it was 3 years ago now with
the The Matrix stuff um so what do you
think I mean the safe bed is for them to
say we're not going to talk about it at
all do you think with what Microsoft
shown off and the relatively positive
reaction to that that maybe they should
they're going to just like stay true to
that and not show it or do you think
they'll maybe show it a little bit well
maybe they'll say something like they'll
acknowledge the interview they did where
they said yep like the Neo is coming but
I don't necessarily think Sony has to at
this point like Microsoft took a step
ahead and there already letting us know
here it is and this is what it's going
to be and we're hyped for it let's get
you hyped for it uh Sony is so far ahead
with the PS4 that I don't think they
necessarily have to be step for step
with Microsoft although it was really
entertaining with the back and forth for
the past couple years with the the
backwards compatibility and the
borrowing the games that video that sh
atam boys did was awesome and seeing
that that uh seeing them too sort of
wore it out was really um was really
entertaining and I kind of missed that
rivalry but I think uh I don't think
they have to and honestly they probably
won't today I feel like there might be
one way that they could at least match
Microsoft is then if they announce like
a price drop for the PlayStation 4 right
currently work if they're not going to
user out new hardware that's a really
easy way for them to earn some points
back didn't they drop they dropped it
already they have but they drop they can
keep dropping it drop it like free
everyone wins everyone gets a free
PlayStation cuz the PlayStation VR is
going to cost
$900 but it comes with a free PS4
exactly PS fre four free free four
whatever if they give away PlayStation
viewers at that conference I'm going to
be real pissed do we have anyone there
actually any Game Spot Scott there
Scott's there Scott's there cuz he has
to be there to get to the PlayStation VR
thing afterwards right he's too new
though we can totally take it from him
yes senior rights for sure uh okay we'll
talk about some VR stuff later on um
we'll dive on into it especially if they
run late but I have a massive list of
games here to talk about which may or
may not turn up here there's another
element of the sunny one which is a lot
of these games are like Sony related but
some of them are just like haven't
turned up anywhere else so you're like
oh okay they're probably going to end up
here but sticking with the Sony stuff
first of all uh The Last Guardian
guessing they're going to show it today
Peter they have to they have to the
games coming out this year they have to
we had just that simple I think we had a
nice little snippet of it last year's
aren which was kind of like obviously it
was different new engine knew everything
but it was it was evocative of the
original launch sort of teaser thing
right sorry so do you think we'll maybe
see some new element of The Last
Guardian this time it's interesting I
mean because they also featured it
prominently at Tokyo game show which was
late last year as well so I'm wondering
like how much they'll actually show us
this year but that being said I feel
like it's kind of dragging at this point
like it really they have to like just a
little yeah just a smidge just yeah just
a little bit like I feel like I don't
know even if they show it at this point
it's almost as if people would just be
like kind of like oh yeah it's that game
like it's kind of like the the time has
come and gone for the yeah in a weird
way they probably don't need to show it
kind of in one way right yeah I mean it
hit so big last year there's nothing
that can top that now like they've
peaked with that already uh speaking of
games that they might have thought they
were going to show this year uh or need
to show this year uh but have since been
delayed a little bit no man's Sky
obviously it's been one of the biggest
games shown at the Sony conferences for
the past couple of years sort of in
spite of the fact that it is basically
an indie procedurally generated game um
what do you think Peter do you think
we'll see it turn up do you think sha
and Murray will be on stage again or do
you think they'll they'll maybe cuz that
there's a there's a sort of a hype issue
with that game right there's a hype
issue because it's hard to really tell
like what is it I we we kind of know
what it is we've seen a lot of the same
footage though and that's the bigger
issue I think if you know one of the
things about that game we don't know a
lot about is sort of how the economies
work right so if they can show that and
sort of the the Nuance like intricacies
of the uh you know why you explore and
what you do with the things you discover
I could be into that they've shown a
little bit before but they could go
deeper um but you know honestly I expect
they're just going to show it in like a
montage that'll probably be it I'd be
shocked if they brought Shawn Murray out
for another yeah honestly long-winded
presentation you think you think the
same Z well like they tend to rotate
like the developers that they have on
stage right I think Shawn M's had his
turn already and that game's had its
turn already so I don't think we'll see
him yeah what do you think Alexa it's
it's pretty soon we're talking first
week of August so yeah so it's not that
far away like delaying it a month and a
half is hardly a delay kind of the same
way Uncharted got delayed a few weeks
just to like right polish stuff up I
played that game for a while a couple
months ago and I like what I played but
I could definitely tell then that like
there's something still missing here
like this is definitely rough and like
Peter said like we haven't really seen
the economies they they have alien NPCs
uh I'm really interested because they
have like uh languages to learn like you
can learn alien languages and customs
and like that's really appealing to me
and if he's going to take more time to
work on it and then maybe show it off a
little bit more to inform my purchase
then like okay I don't think it'll be
there tonight though it was so close to
it was delayed so close to E three yeah
I maybe it wasn't planned to be in the
script since they knew it was coming out
so I don't think we'll see it yeah we'll
have to wait and see I guess yeah it's
an interesting one I think that they've
shown it off quite a lot and they could
probably benefit from giving it a little
bit of space at this sort of s um let's
have a look at another staple of the
Sony family God of War uh there is
rumors of a God of War for Alexa and you
think it's going to be placed in not so
Greek this time nor I I mean other
people have heard this rumor but uh that
it's nor nor now that it's a Norse god
of war and I am
120% behind that I would love to see
that Kratos needs to retire I think it's
his time he can go to the beach and do
his Kratos thing I want to see like a
really awesome like Viking crazy like
God of War yeah name a name a viking God
Thor name a second Viking God oh wow
okay fair enough name Viking
hell oh I don't know that I know valal
is the heaven I don't know Dam it I
meant how and then you have and then you
have and Valkyries Valkyries oh yeah
that's true yeah gosh not since two
human have we had Valkyries in video
games do you remember that remember two
every time you died there was like a
like 90c animation oh then there was
Valkyrie Profile a really great jrpg you
knew way more about Norse mythology than
I was betting on I I'm so sorry I asked
you to answer that question uh that' be
cool uh do you agree like God of War
that katos good call sure if they yeah I
mean they need to do something to make
that series feel fresh again uh I'm not
convinced that like we just had some
footage up here of I think the last game
and it's those that type of game design
is very basic these days right yeah so
beyond just changing the setting in the
character they would have to do
something significant to the game play
or at least the way that it's presented
to kind of get me excited yeah an
Ascension was a little bit of a misstep
maybe sort of little different yeah okay
maybe a large mstep um here's a very
interesting game from a that I feel has
been making the same game for years
Horizon zero dawn has really sort of
captured the attention of a lot of
Gamers uh you know comment ated Gorilla
Games who were sort of stuck working on
Killzone for the longest time Zar what
do you think about Horizon zero Dawn I'm
so excited I think it's a really it's a
really different and interesting take on
post-apocalyptic settings right like and
like it's just something that when
especially when it debuted last year was
something that we've never seen before
and it totally took everyone just like
by surprise and I went and saw like like
them do like a live demo afterwards and
it looked amazing like there was just so
much potential to be like explored there
and I I love like the creatures and the
creature design in that game it's really
interesting and it just feels really
fresh compared to all the other things
that we had yeah and I mean say what you
want a big gorilla big Kill Zone but
that studio has always managed to get
the most out of the PlayStation as well
they've made some fantastic looking
games yeah so yeah it' be interesting
I'm assuming we will see that at some
stage anyway uh everyone put your hands
up for Detroit
put your hands up for Detroit Detroit
I'm into it sorry Peter put your hands
up for Detro thank you David cage
apparently he's in town more polygons
more emotions that yes more more
interactive sex scenes he is six for six
I think at the moment on on having sex
scenes in his game how did you count
that like cuz I've played every David
cage
game maybe it's only five yeah Heavy
Rain uh the the the last one God I can't
remember these names Beyond Two Souls
yeah yeah they renamed it and there's
another one in there somewhere The Nomad
Soul yep well done D they a Bo in that
game yeah so here we go the XM in a
video game we've seen like none of this
right there was that one Tech demo car
car a while ago and then we saw the
trailer which was the sort of this one
which is like the extension of that uh
Peter are you excited about this one do
you like do you like David cage
games no okay do you like David cage
games sometimes Alexa sure I like them
like for in like a you know like certain
directors you're like oh I know what
this movie is going to be like and I do
feel like they've gotten better over
time like they've definitely improved
like Beyond Two Souls was actually a
David cage game that I enjoyed right I
don't dislike his games yeah but just
for something about them I just can't
can't get into but there are those
moments that are really special like
heavy rain sex scenes you're so the show
secret expert on video game SE scenes
Dan apparently you like a spreadsheet of
like the scene the chapter secret got to
hit triangle at the right time that's
what David cage taught me so now that
he's it's the PlayStation 4 it'll be a
really highr yeah 4K 4K Fidelity never
seen s you like it wait for the VR
version VR oh God no awful uh yeah we're
probably going to see Detroit all right
there's nothing else to say dais dais
sorry
to all the French people watching yes
apologies to all our French Brethren uh
let's talk about knack nicknack patty
whac give Don CER you know how like
everyone Mark a bone you call him Don I
called him Don I me Don sery I don't
know why Don matrick I think is where my
bra going there uh Knack was a launch
title there was a resume out there
saying that Knack 2 is a game do we
think Knack 2 is a let's put the hands
out put the hands out up if you think do
we say we think it's a game or we wish
it's a game first think so up up if
think down if not think neck we think
it's game do we want it to be a game
okay there you go Knack was a garbage
game for trash people oh that's a bit H
it was not great it was really just no
like it looked cool but there was just
so much wrong with it be up that t how
cool that is no no but you you have to
admire the concept that they were coming
out with when they first announced it
right they made it sound like can't look
at really nice
creative ay game this game play doesn't
look a bit rough 3 years later at it
right
now this is this is a PlayStation for
launch title and he's what are they
going to call
it he's made he's called Knack because
he's made of knick-knacks do you get it
yeah this would make me want to nots
be KN to Knack again
Knack
harder we're we're minutes away from
realizing the next chapter of Mark C's
Sony Journey so uh stay tuned folks uh
okay let's talk about some of the uh the
third party Staples which are going to
manage to shuffle their way onto the
stage and probably talk about DLC
exclusivity Call of Duty infinite
Warfare we see that on the stage this
year yeah yeah we're definitely going to
see that pretty confident yeah MH will
they show multiplayer or single player
do you think oo both both you think I do
have they shown it at any other
conference I don't know why does it feel
like we've been drinking cuz it's been a
long day we've been drinking the hype
Danny we're all
drunk I'm yeah drunk on hype juice H
okay in the same guys then uh Destiny
rise of iron duh yeah I mean like they
but they've revealed everything there is
to know about that already right they
might be just rehashing like the same
trailer that we saw before and then say
30-day exclusivity on play playst I to
remind you guys that you know you made
the right choice when you bought this
console and speaking of of rumors about
exclusivity there you know we saw Capcom
throw up Dead Rising on their end people
you know they're a company who can't
really make games those types of big
triaa games on their own funding wise uh
the last Resident Evil we saw was six
which was five or six years AG we saw
Resident Evil Revelations too okay yeah
that's true like spin-offs but in the
main like numbered Resident Evil series
it's been like 4 years I think right
could we feasibly see I mean it's
probably a good time for it ending right
there's that rumor that Jordan Amaro was
hired off from Konami he used to work on
KJ Productions right he was hired off to
work on Resident Evil 7 and I mean that
could be a thing cool well I do want to
say last year in April I was in Osaka
and I was sitting in a coffee shop and
um I was just like chilling and two
Capcom devs actually came in and sat
next to me in the coffee shop and I
think they could they probably thought I
only spoke Japanese because they were
speaking English and I heard them
mention Resident Evil 7 really I don't
know I don't know like but the thing was
the way they spoke about it it was like
it wasn't really confirming anything
they were just like kind of like oh yeah
like you know that has really good
potential and blah blah blah so I was
like oh I don't know if that means that
it's actually like in development there
or if they're just kind of like
speculating or like getting excited for
a potential F great what a coincidence
right wow that's actually yeah that's
kind of crazy that that happen just
hanging out Osaka coffee shops waiting
for themop the old school way you just
like spit out
coffee amazing all right we'll have to
wait and see' be so good if it was the
same two people who are on stage
announcing the game that' be hilarious I
hope um so there's also rumors that
sucker punch might be working on a
Spider-Man game this has been floating
around couple week please please let
that be true all right I so maybe I'm
like sensitive to it but I've seen like
three people wearing different
Spider-Man shirts around and then I
remembered we were in LA and that's just
what people do here so it's probably
just normal the county mascot yeah uh so
what would you think about a new new
Spider-Man ass game that'd be great
Sucker Punch knows what they're doing
when it comes to like you know crazy
abilities and environment traversal and
I feel like that is a perfect fit for
Spider-Man so I would love to see that
uh suda 51 let it die zaren you were
talking about it before we went live yes
yes I was I am very curious about this
game cuz they haven't really showed us
much um it's changed a lot for the
duration of like since it was announced
up until the latest trailer so it used
to be called ly burgo and it was like
totally this anime yeah it was
completely different and they kind of
like shifted directions completely and
it's now like this hyper like violent I
mean like in a kind of like unrealistic
colorful artsy way like Let It Die it
just looks very interesting to me
because like we don't know much about
the game and yet everyone thought it was
kind of dead for a while because we
didn't hear about anything for so long
up until a month ago when they released
a trailer out of nowhere so I'm curious
like I'd like to see more like of it
especially since it's a PS4 exclusive I
believe so yeah fingers crossed cool
we've already talked about a bunch of
games uh we are about 133 minutes from
them going live hopefully uh at the Sony
press conference we' have a bunch more
games to get through here uh first of
all let's talk about a game coming out
in November Gran Turismo they take their
sweet sweet time with these ones but GT
Sport out in November any GT fans
sitting on this couch yeah yeah yeah
feel I'm the only one whenever like
racing games are well that's weird
everyone loves Forza well I love racing
games but I didn't know that you like GT
and GT is like in a blind spot for me I
played Gran Turman one and two back in
the PlayStation but I never you missed
some good on I missed gr Turismo was
like not a a racing game but the driving
simul simulator I mean thing there'll
always be our Factor yeah they're trying
they're trying to lean and certainly
when you put it up against Forza yeah
it's it's on the more semi side of
things uh yeah are we looking forward to
some more weird UI and funky Japanese
music you know what I love the UI not
because it's good but because it is just
so like you know that they're so far out
there they're so up their own butt they
don't even know what makes sense
remember the intro for GT4 the intro
video for Grand Turismo 4 was like opera
music and like unable and exactly but
like I I love that about them because
you don't you don't get get that from
any other game right I mean uh I forget
the the lead developer's name from poly
funny digital the company that makes it
but he became a professional or like an
a proam like racer after starting this
game like that's how serious he takes it
they also support like these programs
that like they gather Gamers who like
have really good race times inis and
turn them and train them into like real
life drivers GT Academy so Weir that's
right and they have like that whole
thing so it's like they're taking
themselves really seriously as like
people who I guess kind of invest in
this r i mean look at this UI like even
here what is going on so was say they
totally dropped the ball with uh gr
Turismo uh six what is happening here I
like four what is going on is this like
are we speeding this up or oh so you can
compose scenes to take really sexy
photographs you can just move the cars
sweet dude yeah oh it's like Photo mode
wow move your cars move your
heart what I don't moved by the photo
okay anyway I wonder if David cage knows
this technology I should tell him I
should you should make a Cars game with
a really hot like thear movie or
that' be
great that's senu anyway this game can
be really good if they dial back the
microtransaction model they they made it
like impossible to get new cars in Gran
Turismo 6 it was a real pain in the butt
five was really good I liked it a lot
and then I just was so disappointed by
their last game so if they can fix that
I think they've got a great game on
their hands looks real pretty as well
look at that look at all those colorful
trucks NASCAR ass nonsense look at that
guy spinning on the Nord slide let's
just watch this for the next 15 minutes
look at that car so pretty look at that
car I'll never drive that oh man Arena
probably four of those in the world
beautiful and I love like the low-end
cars that are available in like it's not
just like here's a Honda Civic it's like
the a Honda Civic equivalent from
Switzerland whatever that is here's a
fat Ponto sure yeah it's a wonderful
selection of odd cars it's great what a
weird game I'm delighted it exists um
Sony bend the folks behind Sion filter
recently worked on Uncharted 4
multiplayer apparently they are making a
new game maybe a new IP there's a bunch
of rumors uh going around if there's a
really great neoa thread that sort of
rounds up all the Sony rumors but um
that it's a it's a zombie game great
with
motorcycles Dead
Rising that's dead falling I don't know
um but it's a it's a it's a zombie game
and I guess like Bend has made some good
stuff but I don't want another zombie
game like I think State of Decay is a
really good job with the multiplayer and
like the Dead Rising games do a really
good job with the with with with the
just Raw power and shooting and I guess
Resident Evil and some smaller Indie
titles do a really good job with like
the horror and the jump scares I don't
know that I want another zombie a I feel
like zombies are played out we've kind
of made some real good well not we but
video games have made some really good
zombie games so yeah maybe let's get rid
of that low-end tier of zombie game um
Dark Souls we are probably looking down
the barel of some DLC is that fair to
say Peter Brown yeah I presume that
would makes sense what would you call a
Dark Souls deal DC pack oh God Dark
Souls 3 even darker even okay Dark Souls
3 you call me off guard I'm I I'm
drawing a blank I got nothing we need
Mah Hardy he's really good at that yeah
he's that's why he was sitting here last
time and he was pretty good at it he
came up with Elder Scrolls names like
this all right D should we go get him no
it's all right Serene Dark Souls 3 BL
bloody that's pretty good I go with
skull Blaze SK Dark Souls 3 Dark Again
dark cave of the necro fires of file
no that was the
here oh my God it's funny you mention
Dark Souls actually a story emerged
yesterday from software confirmed that
they're working on three games at the
moment and um one of them is rumored to
be armored Core armed core but what well
like they didn't really say much about
it but a lot of people saying it might
be a reboot yeah like there's a few
different ways that they positioned it
one it was like sort of like a fantasy
game with mechs right which I would hope
would be incorporating the you know the
detailed customization you can do in
armored Core in a different setting but
yeah no it's super exciting what was the
fantasy Mech game that came out on Wii U
last year Xeno Blade Chronicles
[Laughter]
cross yeah that was all right that was
great you likeed that a lot I gave it a
great out of 10 yeah yeah that's eight
that's an eight oh okay it Rhymes wasn't
a grind out of 10 it was a grind very
yeah let's talk about some other games
which have nothing to do with Sony but
may turn up here XCOM 2 is coming out on
consoles it didn't appear at the
Microsoft Booth do they need to show
this off nope no no we know what that
game is I guess instant money people
know if they want XCOM or not yeah yeah
that's good point yeah so it's one of
those games that is among the lowest
searched on Gamespot whenever we were
doing our like meeting despite your
efforts every 20 minutes to type in X
yes I know shame such a good game well
people buy they they like it they buy it
and they play it but they don't really
care about like preview stuff it's like
next com I'll take it I guess yeah the
console version for the first game or
for anyone known H apparently didn't do
super super well which is why they were
focusing on the the PC version this time
around the iPad version is amazing for
yeah I'm sure that did really well so
maybe yeah prob probably a good CH we
won't see that here uh okay how about
some Neo ass games if they they're not
going to show off the Neo we think we
think Neo will they show it
off three out of three my they said no I
mean okay will they show they'll show NE
hey we're not going to show Neo
but see now I have to talk about that no
let's hold on to that for a second will
they show games running on Neo no they
won't show like yo unch 4 look great but
check it out no no no I don't think it's
going to be the sort of difference that
is going to blow people away we're
talking about incremental changes if
anything it's going to be frame rate
that's going to be the difference it's
not difficult to show over internet live
streams I mean that for one and two
they're probably harder than that you
know they realize like Microsoft just
announced a pretty huge um leap in terms
of Technology right and for what we
understand supposedly about Neo it's not
as big granted Microsoft didn't show any
gameplay but at the same time I just
don't think son is going to do it yeah
what what is your take to briefly
sidebar this HDR gaming like the high
dynamic range stuff that apparently is
in like like in like Amazon video and
Netflix and stuff like that and 4K TVs
now have a built in what do you think
that adds much to games like are we is
it literally like is it depth of color
is what we're talking about here it's
depth of value meaning depth of light
and Shadow okay um and that can
interplay with color uh I I don't think
it's it's hugely important but I would
like to have it it would be nice to have
like just knowing that I have the best
representation of of the game yeah I
mean that's always nice I don't think
you're going to be paying a pretty penny
for that so it's not the sort of thing
where it's going to be like do I really
need HDR that's not going to be the
question it's like baked into most 4K
televisions at this stage as well right
I don't know okay not a TV guy no
worries uh okay Neo maybe the worst
titled game ever to be coming out on a
PlayStation 4 Call NE Neato yeah tell me
tell me about Neato is it it's like it's
like Dark Souls but you're a dude who
looks like basically yeah that was a ter
that was words um no it's been that's
also been in development for a very very
long time and like disappeared
disappeared and came back five or six
like that yeah and there was just an ala
did they have they announced a release
date for it yet I don't recall they did
announce a lot of changes like one thing
taking feed to the where durability was
a thing and people were criticizing
about theha the way it wased they just
said we're not going to fix it they just
said okay we just take out durability
really which is kind of scary that's the
way they're fixing that's kind of scary
right that's their mentality that's
their mentality I mean I don't think
that they're just taking away everything
that people aren't totally happy with
cuz that would be crazy it's like you
know you guys don't like encumbrance me
yeah please comat forget it whatever
we'll change him he doesn't look like
anymore looks like Spider-Man way better
all right we we are 3 minutes away from
perhaps the start of the uh Playstation
conference here at the electronic triple
uh We've we've burned through a lot of
the games I wanted to talk about uh
before I go into VR I said I'd dump in
the chat and see if there was anyone
else jump in the chat not dump in the
chat not going to dump in the chat why
would I say that you guys are great
and the one thing a lot of them are
saying I'm talking about is a sequel to
The Last of Us do we think that's too
early for the for this to be talked
about on Charter 4 is miror like six
weeks away six weeks in the in in the
rear view mirror it's never too early
right companies can show a title screen
have a voice actor read a line like they
did when I'm trinis you know yeah it
doesn't take much I mean you saw brought
up that Kojima image the other day and
it was just like a big deal and it's
just it's a slightly altered version of
an image we've already seen I mean
companies know that can drum up hype
especially when the the person they're
representing is so well beloved yeah so
I don't think it's too early okay Red
Dead too I'm sure would that turn up
here Rockstar can do their own thing and
the world will listen like I don't think
they would do it at a press conference
where they're not the center of
attention right so maybe not GTA V was
certainly that way maybe they will maybe
Gamescom that seems crazier think yeah
I'm I'm like a fan of Gamescom but games
bom Gamescom no games bomb 't no E3 no
it's not uh there's been some pretty big
things announced there like scale bound
that wasn't there but they showed it off
yeah all right we'll see okay let's
let's jump into the The Wacky World of
PlayStation virtual reality oh boy here
we go rigs mechanized com bash I don't
even know what that is looks too
complicated sounds like mix that is the
first person Sports ass game made by
it's that UK team I no for a second I
thought it was a Brink people but it's
not them that's under Bethesda I don't
know who it is but they shown it off a
bunch of press conference before uh Gran
Turismo sport has PlayStation VR sport
I'll show that probably that be awesome
harmonics music VR the dance no how does
one dance in VR without badly and with a
high chance of crashing into something
yeah that's dangerous H static I don't
know what that is do you know what
static is doing right now need virtuity
for that fa
tethered like tetherball I play man I
totally played tether
all these things and I'm just like I
you're just making up one word no I'm
not I swear to God you making this up
how we s okay now you're making things
up how we uh okay I think we're are we
starting is that is that actually
happening it's starting all right let's
check it out let's see on other side of
the PlayStation virtual reality
experience stick around here for postc
conference
analysis
[Music]
for
strong
great
SES on
[Music]
see
for
[Music]
[Applause]
sing
[Music]
SA
oh
[Music]
for
all
[Music]
[Applause]
PR
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
stop
[Music]
[Applause]
Ro that dumb Hammer doesn't scare me
boom Oh no
boy
[Music]
boy your mother's knife it belongs to
you
now what for a
test she taught you to hunt yes yes sir
then show me what you
know I am
[Applause]
hungry feed
us what are we hunting
you are hunting
deer which way your hunt you tell me
South is that a question
[Applause]
[Music]
sou look tracks they're fresh this
[Applause]
way found it slow down
boy sorry you must think do not simply
react be calm and
plan it's just I'm not used to
hunting
oh what happened
here there it is
hold what are you doing now it's guard
is up only
fire only fire when I tell you to
fire I'm sorry do not be
sorry be
better find
[Applause]
it
find
[Music]
[Applause]
it my no you are not ready stay
back
[Applause]
fog I knew something fell off about the
forest keep
moving you know if you give me my bow
back I can help you fight I'm ready you
have yet to prove that I need a chance
you had a chance I need another then
find that
deer
back away
[Music]
boy here's a chance show me already yes
sir back get a clean Ang and space your
shots I will want to me
[Music]
what do we do now shoot it on
it
father it is time I will bring it down
you will kill
it
now
boy
wait do
it off the ice
no
I am so sorry
I your dear is getting
away yes
sir
[Music]
I can't believe we fought a real troll
and you froze when I told you to kill it
I know but you staring right at how
could I the eyes him I thought your
mother taught you to hunt she did but I
never had to kill anything she always
did that part then it is time for you to
learn
father
look wait for my
mark relax do not think of it as an
animal it is simply a Target clear your
[Music]
mind
exhale and
[Music]
release I got
good still
[Applause]
alive your knife
[Music]
no finish what you
started I
can't
[Music]
I
now you are
ready for
[Music]
what a new
beginning
[Music]
please welcome to the stage Sean
[Applause]
Laden good
evening good evening everyone and
welcome what a way to start at the show
huh with a live demo of God of
War right now Al a special thank you and
a shout out to our very talented
composer of the soundtrack to God of War
Mr bar
[Applause]
mccu here tonight with his awesome
Orchestra and they'll be performing all
evening so that's that's really exciting
for all of us thanks to
everybody um before before we go any
further though um I think it's important
that we take a moment
to uh to address the the heartbreaking
tragedies of Orlando this past
weekend a horrific event like that
carried out by a Madman really
underscores our need for for greater
love tolerance and respect of people of
all
kinds on behalf of the PlayStation
Community I just want to say that our
thoughts are with uh the victims and the
families and the community of Orlando uh
we stand four square with them and we
hope that in this week of perhaps our
gaming celebrations within the diversity
of our Gaming Community we can find some
strength some comfort and some Solace uh
the PlayStation Community stands for
square with our friends and fans in the
LGBT community as well uh and I know
they're all uh in the hearts of everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight
so without the transition sounding
awkward please bear with me but I would
like to welcome you all to the historic
Shrine Auditorium we've been away from
this venue for a while but now we're
back we're delighted to be here because
it is a temple to creativity and to all
that and to all that means we're proud
to be
part of a vast and expansive team of
storytellers artists Engineers
musicians and programmers and
actors the massive and sometimes
sometimes tiny teams who tirelessly
create works of art that we find
ourselves getting lost
in and that is what tonight is all about
for the next hour we will we hope to
Astound you with a lineup of games that
are both dazzling and
transformative with a few surprises
along the way so without further Ado I'm
proud to take you on this journey to
some of the great games coming out on
PlayStation 4 please enjoy the
[Applause]
[Music]
show someone asked me once if I
remembered how it all went down
as if it happened so long ago that
anyone could
forget so yeah I
[Music]
remember I remember when our homes and
our towns turned into
graveyards when the Wilderness became
our only hope for
survival I remember when the planes fell
out of the
Skies when the trains stopped
running when the turbines shut down
and the world went
dark I remember when they put up the
razor
wire like it was going to stop
anything and the FEDS ran out of body
bags bro broke and some of us sort of
lost our minds I think it's
dead some lost more than that much
more I remember when we lived by a code
when Brotherhood meant something and
living meant more than surviving you
godamn liar so yeah I remember how it
all went down work working I I don't
give a damn about any of
that you know what I remember
most riding the open
road the smell of your
hair the touch of your
skin I remember you
but those days are
gone now I'm a
Drifter a bounty hunter a
mercenary and for me the Broken Road is
all that's
left but I'll always
remember
[Music]
[Applause]
hry
[Music]
my
[Applause]
this are you
[Music]
[Applause]
agree
the
[Music]
turn back corrupted machines in the
valley I have to cross I'm headed for
the Border then may the goddess show
[Music]
Mercy
shell Walkers let's have a
[Music]
look I should focus againand
them got some weak spots but they're
tough risky but I need the
[Music]
components
two explosive traps coming right
[Music]
[Applause]
up
help help
help watch out it's
corrupted
[Music]
you did
it I came from Mother's rise corrupted
attack the village yes and something
worse a
demon what do you mean a demon it
scuttled from the forest drove a group
of Watchers mad how' it do that I saw
but I did not understand oh goddess
protect
us keep running for mother's Crown it's
not far come with me or the demon will
kill you I don't believe in demons and I
don't run when lives are at stake get
out of
[Music]
here you're
crazy
[Music]
The
Village I'll never make it in
time unless I get a
mount
broadheads if I override one of those
that should
do
[Music]
sorry not
today
[Music]
the
The
[Music]
Village what's that
noise what the hell is
that it's corrupting The
Watcher vulnerable to
fire here we
go
that was
close
he's strong all
right
yeah
try jumping
now
[Music]
this machine it looks
ancient where did it come
from
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been just over an hour since a
little girl was taken hostage on the top
floor of a building here in downtown
Detroit details are still emerging on
what exactly happened but the hostage
shaker could be the family's
Android negotiator on
site please please you got to save my
little
girl
wait you're sending an Android all right
ma'am we need to go you can't do that
you why aren't you sending a real
person captain alen my name is Connor
I'm the Android sent by cyberlife it's
firing in everything that moves it
already shot down two of my
men saving that kid is all that matters
so I you deal with this Android
now or I'll take care of
it don't come any closer or I'll
jump no no please I'm beging you hi
Daniel my name is
Connor there's no way out Daniel the
only question is whether or not you take
another innocent life I'm holding
holding all the cards if I die she dies
look what you did you were designed to
serve humans not kill them what was I
designed to be their slave their toy
you're a machine you have to obey now
Put the gun down and let the hostage go
I've spent my life taking
orders now it's my turn to
decide
your order for an AP Android has been
registered are you armed
no I have a gun drop
it touch him and I kill
you you can't kill me I'm not
alive tell that helicopter to get out of
here
it's up to you how the story
[Music]
ends I trust
you
you lied to me
Connor you lied to
me my name is
Connor this is our
story
[Applause]
[Music]
I hated kitchen kitchen was
no no not
King if you don't get out of there they
will kill you get out now
going
[Music]
you
a
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
okay what the am I supposed to do
God damn it I'm probably going to end up
like Andre
okay what the
what are you see what is it what are you
going back
here
[Music]
no
and go tell
and tell and
r I
be
[Music]
it's
amazing in addition in addition to the
PS4 console experience
the full Resident Evil 7 will be
playable from beginning to end with
PlayStation
VR when it releases on January 24th nope
2016 is a sual moment in virtual reality
the time has finally come for everyone
to enjoy VR in their own
homes and at PlayStation we have a
combination of the necessary processing
and Graphics power already built inside
40 million PS4s that have been sold
worldwide
we thank you for
that we have the display technology
which can realize these images at a high
fidelity we have the production
expertise to create a headset that is
designed for the gamer and because
PlayStation 4 is a fixed platform
developers can fine-tune their games for
the system to deliver the same
transformative experience for all
PlayStation VR owners
I'm happy to announce here that on
October 13th PlayStation VR will make
its debut in the United
[Applause]
[Music]
States currently more than 50 games will
be available from launch until the end
of this
year that includes some of the biggest
franchises along with brand new titles
that will be born on
psvr we invite those here tonight after
the experience and after this experience
to come with us next door to the arena
post reception where we'll be able to
have some psvr kiosk set up so you can
all have a
go now I'd like to Showcase a few
PlayStation VR titles starting with
PlayStation exclusives developed by our
own worldwide studios please watch
[Music]
my
God this place is
incredible what your suit on those rocks
you don't know what kind of pathogens
might exist here we can't afford a
[Music]
breach come on we have to keep
moving I bet this place isn't even on
the star
charts analyzing
surroundings unknown
environment unknown atmosphere wow
unknown
[Music]
location
wait what the hell is
[Music]
that
wel to you copy do you see
this grant grant are you there Eva
Eva we got to move
now Pilgrim can you read me this is Dr
Tyson and Dr Moon come
[Applause]
[Music]
back all wings
reported
Blue 5 standing
by this is blue n reporting in we're
with you blue
leader ready for
combat clear to
[Music]
engage
how do you feel when you put on that
mask are you hiding from the world or do
you want the world to hide away from
you maybe you feel
Invincible more than just a man or maybe
you're just like me you see that life is
nothing but a sick joke and so you
choose a face to
match but what happens when we become
what we pretend to be when illusion
becomes the new
reality does it even matter after all if
you find a mask that fits you never need
to take it
off
[Music]
[Applause]
don't stop we just won quit
[Music]
you're on
ice
[Music]
[Applause]
woo
that ought to do
her this shouldn't take
long so it down
now hit it yeah
let stay
there
[Music]
[Applause]
TR
[Music]
w
enemy surging in multiple sectors LT
they're taking ground let's keep this on
a tight Loop and get back out there
[Music]
Rees captain on the bridge get us
underway salt right away sir Captain has
a con Raven one docking you're touching
down now M good station Time 1 minute
Roger
that
we've got four new hot spots on radar
sir check app ploted course on your
order sir what's our Target Rees standby
for
objective we've got a set de destroyer
in lunar orbit we'll coordinate a
takedown with tigis let's Mount up
Lieutenant any questions jackles up on
Bay three Captain Gentlemen let's get it
done
Captain Ethan's already in back
sir you said Ethan Good To Go
sir solar wind Should Be steady good
hunting Captain thanks
at let's go green on the Catapult you
spun up favor Gage hyra time nozzle's
good let's hit
it Jackal 1112 Tower advises time to tet
320 and 5 check 11 Roger
two good Deon moving
up scar1 you're locked for go Roger
we're lit launch in three 2
1 they're launching
Skelter I got one on me counter
measures just
12 on my way hang in there I got this
weapons
away no joy no joy easy salt
easy I'm getting boxed in Raider
throttle up coming to
you got a shot box
out actual Raider is inbound aboard a
disable enemy warship stand by
got our B banded 12:00 High eyes on
tigers for visual ghost guard Jack is
down CR off coming up boots out in three
2 1 go go go one two away one one is
away Bridge get ahead sir Raj let's get
there we got
hostiles more
incoming set up transport
inbound dig
in they're inserting reinforcements
drive them
back more from
below keep
pushing on of the bridge top of the
bridge
[Music]
zone is clear here's our info their
blast Shields are up copy Tigers we are
exterior of the bridge preparing to
breach
force in let's
go staff sergeant cover the exit Ethan
restore life support hi sir salt scope
the windows I get the CO's card alert
this vessel has been compromised all
Personnel to bridge respons hold
activating
gravity Tiger's actual weapons are down
moving to xville go loud think we got
their attention clear the ho coming down
the stairs second level 1 minute let's
go got him G from the control room
behind the pillar B ass control room
ahead Shield
up taking cover
reloading de pressurize and grab
hold Tigress we need Birds copy sending
ja
gun's approaching
overhead Jacks are in copy load
up set Turn and
Burn tiger scars are clear copy clear
engaging weapons
loose
[Applause]
[Music]
our blood has been
spilled looks like we're rolling in with
everything
[Music]
15,000
oh my tang
tang Marines we have a possible fix on
all side of the capital city Intel
gathered by SAS indicates that alassad
may have a Russian Warhead speed is
critical we have visual on the target
ETA 6
second move
move hway
clear
move it move it get
up
[Music]
beautiful we are
leaving let's do
[Applause]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah that's
right no T-shirt tonight but
I'm proud to announce that we work with
our partners at
Activision who're going to bring back
the original crash crash 2 and crash
warped fully remaster from the ground up
for PlayStation
4 Crash Bandicoot will also appear first
though uh on PlayStation 4 this October
in Skylanders imaginators so let's have
a look at that
[Music]
what if I
go
[Music]
w wow
w
[Music]
[Applause]
dear
[Music]
child I see your
eyes the belonging you seek is not
behind you it is
ahead the Droid I'll pay for him
actually the droids are not for
sale come
on I can do
this the Droid stole a freighter the two
were accompanied by a
girl what
girl ch for home this joint has to get
to the resistance base as soon as
possible he's carrying a mat to Luke
Skywalker Don't Tell Me a r are has
gotten
loose I got a bad feeling about
this girl heard so much
about don't move
I'm in charge
now it's about time you showed
up give it everything you
got you're
afraid you will never be as strong as
Darth
[Music]
Vader we're not done
yet you might need it
ow
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
goodness
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome to the stage Andrew
House
thank you very much everyone uh it's an
absolute honor to be here at E3 our
mission is to make PlayStation the best
place to play for gamers and I think
you'll agree that this E3 marks one of
the strongest lineups of content in
PlayStation
history that's a result of our
commitment to Partnerships with the most
talented developers and storytellers in
our
medium and as proof of that commitment
please join me in welcoming one of the
most creative talents in the history of
Gaming
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hello everyone I'm
back
thank you today I bring something new uh
we move we made for you and this is all
uh running in real time please
[Applause]
enjoy
[Music]
the
realness
[Music]
[Applause]
F to take
[Music]
this head
on soon now come
[Music]
around Lo
never waiting for
[Applause]
my
[Music]
see bued
underr
but I'll keep
[Music]
coming
keep
[Music]
com
yeah I keep
coming
[Applause]
people see me and think they're
safer but it's not really me they're
seeing
probably for the best knowing everything
hinges on a guy from Queens sounds as
scary as it
[Music]
feels no pressure
right
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
w
everyone sometime in your life should
have the ability to walk on with an
orchestra it's the most amazing thing
ever let me tell you thank you guys so
much
uh Tim take it
out we are on the verge of a future
unlike any other thanks to the
dedication and the passion of the Great
greatest Gaming Community of all
time we we are committed to delivering
the future Technologies and experiences
that will continue to evolve console
gaming we thank you our partners our
allies our friends for going along with
us on this journey thank you you're
welcome at the at the
core at the core of interactive
entertainment is the con it's play right
as much we love to talk about about
stories and visuals and emotions and
graphics and Technology it all comes
together in the Brilliance of
gameplay so before I leave it is my
distinct pleasure to share a live demo
with all of you of a title we introduced
earlier tonight but we'll see it played
live thank you for coming ladies and
gentlemen day is
gone
he's headed to the Old
Sawmill going in after it's going to be
dark soon when does that ever stop
me
his bike's
[Music]
down all right two dog where the hell
are
[Music]
you
oh
go on get out of here get
out well that ain't
[Music]
him all right let's
see yep I could use
that
[Applause]
[Music]
oh oh
two
dog get out here son of
dog damn
it stop to
dog
look around brother you know how this is
going to
end where you
[Music]
at
[Applause]
yeah son of a
oh oh
come on come
[Applause]
on
[Music]
oh am I going to go am I going to
go
sh
come on come on come on come on come
on come on come
[Applause]
on
[Music]
[Applause]
you can
clim swi
[Music]
you can into the
fire but you never be
free we can
make we
can
L
station
[Applause]
Danny are you
okay I don't think any of us are okay I
don't even know what okay means anymore
so we're going to we're going to break
this down real professionally like game
by game right but can we just take like
20 seconds just what the was that
only W again oh my gosh you know what
they're
doing clear right I have sweat in my
palms no BS I'm tired they just packed
it all in trailer after trail trailer
there's no there's no like slowing down
at all no they're like yo new kajima
game baby Norman re naked God of War
live demos off everything David Cage's
game looks all right even Peter was like
I'd buy that dude I'm into it new
Spider-Man game I mean we called so much
of this stuff before 15 VR Resident Evil
can be play start to finish in virtual
reality you can play it tonight you can
play the demo tonight see you guys I'm
out you know all right okay shake off
the cobwebs and stop thinking about
Norman Reedus's naked ass and his
C-section get to that in a second uh
okay where to start you know what
actually let's just start with that
death stranding that is the new game
from hideo Kojima and Kojima Productions
Peter Brown uh little bit of a sort of a
clue towards this we saw on Jeff Key's
YouTube live show earlier today yeah
Jeff key had kajima on YouTube and he
was like you know you're always someone
who likes to sort of play with
expectations and you know you drop
little hints when people least expect it
and Kim's like oh yeah yeah K's like I
don't know for all we know maybe your
shirt is given something away was like
Oh and it was it was L letters DS with
some strands hanging from it so it was
100% a hint and wow yeah Okay who wants
to tackle this one let's try and figure
out what game this is here's Norman Reus
with digital handcuff electronic
handcuffs a baby with a wire yep that's
a baby it's a little bit healthier those
Wireless
babies got a butt there's handprints on
his butt there's H yes there hand all
over him there's a there's handprints
all over hims all super happy that the
baby is cutting to me I miss the baby
where' the baby go um it's it's it was
with you all along Danny slightly
healthier looking baby than in PT uh but
yeah they show that the baby disappears
I don't even know love their babies hide
Kim is making a new video game Alexa yes
he is it's called and Norman rus' butt
is in it death stranding and Norman Reus
is in it and that's all we know okay
let's hands out hands out look
handprints more handprints we we good
we're all we're three for three we're
we're doing hands out hands out yep all
right all three up looks good look at
that look at that scar oh my God like
it's oh my God there is so much
symbolism in this that I don't even know
where to begin like all these random
things like out of place and out of six
dog tags on them are they dog tags hog
into dog tags I don't know they look
like yeah like little like yeah like
tombstones and then if you saw in the
sky there were like these weird thing
yeah like what five
thing men like icons of humans or
something it kind of reminded me of
Evangelion like when they had the some
of the angels that were on the
crosses yeah like okay
yeah that's that's that's it that's what
huima is up to now nothing to do with
that ludin ludin I wouldn't be surprised
if it did right what's ludin ludin is
the character you their mascot that they
showed that teaser image of oh yes I
mean it said I'll keep coming that was
the title of the song that they were
using over the trailer yes so presumably
it's more than just a mascot at this
point my God all right let's can we stop
let's stop looking at this cuz I feel
like my I'm already ass sure that I'm
going to have nightmares about this this
evening so if we can just like create a
little bit of a buffer maybe a maybe a
katos buffer uh we talked about uh God
of War maybe being shown God of War 4
Alexa you were saying hey I hear maybe
some sort of Norse god of war game um it
is and it's just straight off called God
of War and Kratos is back as well
training his son to do something yep his
son who sucks at hunting so it's a it's
a it's a dading God of War yeah much
like Gears of War this is the new trend
we're seeing uh yeah Peter before we
went live you were saying look if they
had to go back to God of War that the
gameplay of those old games it's a
little bit trce you know in 2016 they're
going to have to shake it up uh this is
what they did right I mean it's it's
maybe it's not maybe it's not new but
it's like very different anyway it's a
previous got to I mean changing the
perspective by bringing the camera this
close to Kratos is a smart move and
honestly it was sort of the thing that I
was hoping because watching the gameplay
before from the top down thing it was
just like man like we need to be in this
action you know not like during just a
cut scene battle but actually like in
the momentto moment gameplay and sure
enough here we are seeing that um it's
super impressive and I'll be honest like
the the sort of the moment with him and
his son when the animal was dying I've
never seen anything like that in a god
of war game before like something that
actually felt like inspiring emotion
from me like I I'm super impressed by
the whole demo for the most part I'm
honest yeah like big tonal shift from
the God of War you know hurah tearing
things head off and having like sex
scenes with the yeah you know like they
they dive into that in a much deeper way
you know what I mean yes we'll have to
see I guess they dive into the sex
scenes much deeper they do much deeper
umit yeah triangle buttons um do we
think you will play as the child do we
think this is a prologue to a game where
you play as the kid you do a little bit
I mean they sort of show you get to aim
his bow and arrow so I presume yeah
that's a good indication what do you
think Alexa um I'm really excited that
uh there's no fixed camera right I like
that you can explore the world I totally
think uh I mean if you're training the
kid if they're rebooting this they're
going to do a series presumably in this
God of War era maybe the next game if
there is another game is the kid like
maybe this is you preparing him to
become the new God of War well what do
we think about I guess the what we're
looking at here in terms of you know era
or culture or whatever cuz it doesn't
like like I know nothing about North
ology but it doesn't immediately jump
out of that to me so when that guy
popped out he said something something
something Valhalla yeah okay all right
so there you go but it's though when
Kratos used his like rage thing it's
called Spartan rage so it's it's not
like some sort of like weird reboot of
the character I mean it's the same same
iteration yeah you think it's Kratos
just like years later he's just like you
know what is messed up I'm going to go
to
Norway get out of here Iceland maybe uh
yeah interesting stuff maybe it's like a
different interpretation of the God of
War right like SP rage right there yeah
yeah that's like you know it's all back
and they didn't really reveal his name
either right so be we don't be cradles
filling in the blanks here look at that
look at that look how angry he is I
really like the beard think the beard is
a big Improvement I love that he just
starts punching it here even though like
he has the weapon strapped to his back
but he's totally igned it and like just
going straight for it's more about the
message you send then I think well he
wants his son to get the the final kill
right this was pretty funny I mean he
gets XP the fluffed it a little bit he's
going to get that kill dead ratio and
then nope oops hit my dad it's good
thing he's Kratos or maybe katos uh okay
moving on I guess uh God of War looked
very good we then saw after that we saw
a very good demo or a very short trailer
for what Ben Studios were working on
which we did again talk in the pre-show
H day gone we saw a trailer for it and
then at the end of the show I mean
pretty good for a showstopper we saw
gameplay of it uh Alexa what did you
think of that well you before we went on
air you said all hype for Dead Rising
they hijacked they hijacked us they did
this is incredible I mean it's a
different type of zombie game you know
we we again at the pre-show we were
talking about zombie games and saying
like you
know eventually somebody has to do
something different and Dead Rising was
something different back in whatever it
was 2007 or so um and the new ones are
obviously like evoking that as well but
like in this you know I dare say
realistic but more grounded in realism
in terms of of the the combat at least
like he spends most of his time at the
end of this demo fleeing a massive horde
of zombies yeah yeah Peter what did you
think of this bed boy uh I was very
impressed by how the the series of
events just sort of chained together um
and how you know one minute it's kind of
Cal and Serene and it wasn't like he was
entering an area where it was like okay
this is zombie time like it just it all
seemed to happen uh just very
organically and unfold in a way that was
a surprise to not only us but obviously
the character as well yeah zene what did
you think so when they first showed the
trailer at the beginning of the
conference I wasn't sold I thought the
dialogue was a bit cheesy and kind of
weak and it was just like another oh
it's another post-apocalyptic you know
zombie game whatever and I wasn't you
know like I was like oh I guess that
looks kind of interesting I guess but
then they showed all the gameplay and I
was like wo like you're tackling a
massive horde you know it all kind of
escalates really quickly I'm really
interested to see what else like the
game lets you do I'm interested to see
how open it is as well because with
zombie games we almost sort of by
default consider them to be open world
so many of them are right or at least
sort of in large areas uh this one with
like you know there was a very sort of
direct connection between him you know
grabbing that muffler out of the car and
then using it as a silencer and then you
know the way it sort of escalated was
quite you
knowed like some sort of linearity to
this but they've masked it really well
yeah so I wonder if that's the overall
game as like this could very much just
be like the last of us then that is you
know very very scripted I mean even so
this looked impressive yeah that H at
the end was tendous came out of nowhere
yeah uh incredible like technically
impressive as well it even looked good
before any of the sort of the population
went up as well like even at the start I
sort of remarking on it he just let that
guy get he didn't even finish him off
disgusting H let's let this play on
because I just I want to see this
nonsense when they all start piling up
and like it's like a wave I like when
the bridge collapses under their weight
there one section where they like inside
that warehouse where the bridge kind of
just collapsed and fell through like
under all that weight and I thought well
that'd be interesting like look at this
I love how he's he's using the gun
almost to just like stem the tide like
not to stop it but just be like the emmo
though it's just like he keeps pulling
it out of nowhere yeah he's like you
know eventually they'll all be dead I
just need to do like 10% of the work
every single time I turn around that's
genuinely terrifying that wave of like
zombies is genuinely terrifying and the
sound cuz I had I had the the conference
audio piped into my ear and it was just
this like screaming like constant
level of of screaming the entire way
through this demo I mean this bit here
is just this is just awful like how
unbelievably terrifying like even the
animation there Peter it's pretty
impressive looking right it is very good
yeah and just to see how they all run on
top of each other and Tumble and chist
it's it's incredible to that this is a
live demo because the moment I started
watching I'm thinking like it doesn't
how can it look this good right but then
of course they've got those windows over
there to prove me wrong like this is
this is very impressive yeah yeah
unbelievable stuff he almost gets away
with it as well like fair play mate like
even coming up top of the ceiling
there's one zombie just hanging out on
that roof waiting for his time uh yeah I
mean who knows like it'll be interesting
I think a lot of people are going to
have eyes on this immediately kind of
like Horizon zero Dawn last year where
suddenly gorilla were getting inundated
with request it'll be very interesting
to see if this is a game that's you know
a bit more cu the way he's controlling
seems open world or seems like a game
that gives you that I don't know like
it's it's not like just con it's not
like the camera is very scripted it kind
of feels like or very tight it feels
like it's giving you a certain amount of
uh of freedom and here's where it all
goes wrong for a dear
friend also got a weird Lost and Damned
Vibe out of it with the mot bikes I mean
Alexa did say literally before the show
that it was a zombie biker game zombies
with motorcycles yeah yeah yeah so you
were not wrong look at this nonsense we
should probably talk about another game
but just look at this nonsense I don't
know it's like I was really hyped for
Dead Rising 4 and then this happened and
I was like oh okay yeah ring W change of
pace here look at this this this is just
dumb I expected the bridge to collapse
here too actually I just want bridge I
love that there look like tumbling over
each other and just like falling like
that's so that guy is so delicious the
bodies remain do they always remain
that's what I want to know like all the
bodies stay there at all times yeah you
to loot them all one by one just hold
square over every single one of those
guys yeah Jesus unbelievable look at all
those zombies ridiculous uh okay let's
let's move it on let's shuffle along uh
we got a bunch more games to talk about
we did not see PlayStation Neo they did
show off Sony VR and they showed off a
bunch of pretty interesting games for
Sony VR let's talk about the hardware
first though uh$ 3.99 for the basic
version there is a499 version uh which
includes I guess the move controllers
the camera and then some software with
it as well H what do you think about
that Peter in terms of uh price point we
knew the price already I we did did we
know the price I pre-ordered it months
ago oh okay well then let's forget about
that and I even thought it was
October I guess it's news but I thought
we knew this maybe we did already I like
I'm pretty sure we did so considering
the price point what did you think about
the software that they were showing it
uh well I don't want to steal the show
by mentioning the one big one for BW me
Resident Evil 7 man yeah I I'm okay the
news that Jord Maro was working on that
game the guy used to work Konami was
involved with PT two degree it makes
perfect sense that that game has such PT
Vibes yes it looks freaking incredible I
will be terrified to play that in VR
right I just thoroughly Blown Away not
only by what I was seeing but from the
fact that Capcom is making that game
that Capcom has taken a series and
turned and pivoted it so hard and not
only that it's like PT has been brought
back from the dead as Resident Evil
Silent Hills has become Resident Evil
like how the hell does that happen so
crazy I mean obviously the story and
themes are probably different but this
is the I mean if you're not getting pt5
vibes from this we played different
games right uh this is coming out of
PlayStation 4 PlayStation exclusive also
fully playable from start to playstor
what do you think about that Alexa um so
I can't really handle jump
scar I I did the whole time I'm sitting
there like this but I wanted but I I
always go for stuff like this even
though it scares me I am totally in like
this looks like classic Resident Evil
and that's what that series freaking
needs in a in a weird way it's like the
opposite of Resident Evil's camera which
used to be so fixed and then they're
just like look every want but it's that
same sort of enclosed you know super um
you know what's around the next Corner
scary kind of thing God crazy resid Evil
7 I mean yeah Capcom splitting the
difference between Microsoft and Sony
but you got to say Sony's probably
gotten the better at 2D as rine yes um
and can I just say Osaka coffee shop was
right like my god with those hot Scoops
it was totally a thing but this
completely took me by surprise also the
throwback to The Biohazard name I
thought was interesting cuz you know
that's that's what Resident Evil is
called in Japan it's called biohazard so
do you think that's what they're calling
it Resident Evil 7 biohazard I think I
read a press release that came out after
this was shown in Japanese and and it
said like Resident Evil like and the
evil was like with the V right with the
um the Roman numerals and it had
biohazard as well so that's what they're
calling it over there I am super excited
like when this trailer was playing I I
was like is this no this can't be like
Resident Evil is not first person like
this right like I'm curious to see how
it'll be played when you're not in v yes
absolutely I'm curious how it's going to
tie into the the world of Resident Evil
no absolutely like we don't know
anything about the character or like who
this is like you're playing or where
like salent has done the you know inside
of one house thing before as well as PT
but uh yeah it's yeah how big is this
right that's the that's another question
I think yeah and is it just a one place
or bunch of levels so many questions uh
and also so many other VR games they
showed off Faro which is a sort of
firsters Planet shoot thing looked all
right uh Star Wars Battlefront getting
X-Wing VR Missions uh we don't know if
that's Standalone or not I'm hoping it
is I'm guessing it is uh we also saw
Final Fantasy in virtual reality Alexa
what Alexa cried I lost my freaking mind
it looked weird he just shooting the
thing it looked weird you play as
prompto so prompto is the best one he's
just shooting the thing they all do the
Final Fantasy stuff but that's crazy
like we've never we've never had AOS
like this kind of experience with Final
Fantasy with at all this is awesome look
at this why is it awesome because you
get to you're like you're in the game
you are fed up why is nobody else
excited now you are a Final Fantasy
character maybe they're not excited to
hang out with these guys like come on I
would be excited to hang out's just
shooting it he's standing right there
I'm going to shoot this Final Fantasy
thing you're that's crazy though like
square is like really going all out with
15 yeah yeah they are
they've even done VR look at look at
that he's blocking them shoot him he's
like shoot him with your VR helmet okay
they also said they're going to have 50
games released on Playstation VR by the
end of 2016 my gosh 50 games 50
different experiences let's stop talking
about virtual reality we got more games
to talk about yeah put your hands up for
Detroit yeah yeah Peter's in Peter Brown
is in got me cage David cage David kaj
with his latest game d totally sold H
you play as some sort of you play as the
worst character in heavy rain but as an
Android a police detective don't blame
his robotic acting anymore true nice my
guy died on the second mission in heavy
rain I never got to play him again so
maybe that's what I like um but yeah
this looked pretty interesting right
Peter yeah I I I super love the idea of
Androids and the question of
Consciousness and identity and this
obviously is tackling that like full
boore uh and all of the various
possibilities that can play out seem
very interesting especially with the
high stakes in the scene they were
showing M I was like there's no way that
during this demo they're going to show
that girl like get thrown off the roof
no way and then it happened but I
understand why because they balanced it
out so like this is a game that seems
very interesting to me given the themes
at hand and the possibilities to explore
those like in great depth yeah like
massive Blade Runner Vibes coming off it
obviously detective story and Android as
well I'm in uh I was really impressed by
the pullback when it showed all the
different ways it could have gone and
what it could have done like that's
really compelling to me there's not like
two answers there's like a couple and
the acting stuff has gotten so good I'm
also kind of like I'm really relieved
they haven't used the celebrity this
time cuz there was something about
Beyond Two Souls that it was like it
felt like it was grabbing me out of it
all the time I like Norman Reus though
we sure do love that guy sure yeah
that's so far in the other direction
it's like I know it's like too much uh
yeah I'm the same as you I'm like I feel
like this happens every time I do have a
cage game I'm like I'm back in but I'm
back in but it was kind of weird though
the thing they were saying they were
like face dilemas gather information
threw me off the game like before I saw
all the branching storyline stuff when
they were putting all this cheesy text
into it to really make it sound like
like it felt like they were overselling
it to me and it felt almost a little bit
cheesy and I was like oh come on like
really like that's a bit too much like
you know this this kind of St things
could have been different you know like
collect information like well yay
collect information that's really ex I
face dmas every day
I know right but um like this kind of
stuff I thought was interesting like you
know going back through you know what
happened in the scenario and
backtracking I'm interested to see how
you actually play the game is it like
whatever happens you can't go back like
or do you just restart the game and play
in like many different trees like say I
don't know until dawn yeah that kind of
stuff yeah I would like a a David cage
game which is actually replayable from
start to fin or it's compelling me to do
that cuz as much as I love those other
games they're very much like one one and
done sort of things uh yeah very
interested let us know what you think of
Detroit in the comments below we have
more games to talk about folks let's
talk about Gorilla Games as Horizon zero
Dawn uh I feel like every time they
showed this game I'm more and more
impressed uh by it Alexa what did you
think uh I'm really like that you can
hack the the creatures now like sort of
use them make a mount um we got a little
bit more of the story I think she was
talking about corrupted and like
machines being older and like not
knowing where it came from but I'm
really into like you said earlier I'm
really into the idea of a different
postapocalypse where uh like machinery
and that kind of stuff still exists and
it has overrun us also there's a rabbit
so there are animals yes which is good
there are real anals important that
there are still aninals H yes you are
hacking animal robot animals to make man
and also just straight up like stealing
components out of these dumb dumpster
truck robots Peter what did you think of
horizon zeroed da when it comes to
stealing components that was the thing
they showed last year and I really like
that concept but one thing that has me
worried about this game is the fact that
it seems to be relying so heavily on the
ju position of two very different eras
and and I'm just I don't want that to be
the thing that is supposed to make this
game interesting because on the like for
me just that alone doesn't do it right I
need to I need to know how these
characters are interacting what role
they play and all of that the action
looks great you know like I could see
that being fun and interesting and
challenging and certainly dynamic in in
a lot of interesting ways but in terms
of the world I'm just not sold yet right
and one of the things I was very
impressed by and they did sort of show
last year with that big T-Rex style
fight was the boss fights and how you
need to sort of actually use some smarts
to to overcome them right h z what did
you think about the the fight in this
one she was kind of like using flame
arrows and then you planting traps and
stuff I really like how they gave you
options so you could tackle a battle in
whatever like strategic way you wanted
right like shooting like the ropes to
tie the thing down you know that was one
way to limit the movement of the monster
and I just thought it was a really cool
way of them like explaining
how to do certain things in the world
right so for example like taming that
Beast to ride it like some games have
you know you get to tame horses you get
to tame this you get to have mounts
their way was you know you're taking
over a robotic mind and like it becomes
your your friendly Mount and I thought
that was like a really cool way to
approach a mechanic that we've seen
before but in a very different way I
love the fact that you could then you
know use that within the boss fight as
well it wasn't as if they saying okay
here we are boss fight let's go like
this does feel like it feels feel like
they're trying to make an open world
game with all of these different systems
that interact with each other um which
you could argue they never did with
Killzone Killzone was a straight up
first person shooter um that you know
there wasn't much in the way of you know
dynamic gameplay or emerging gameplay
happening or anything like that uh but
there seems to be like little bits of
that where they're at least like giving
you the sort of sandbox saying this is
how it works it's got crafting so it has
to be open world yeah yeah for sure no
I'm serious like I don't think you can
have a game with crafting that's not
open world looks pretty as well man that
rope gun look at that her hair looks
awesome I'm just yeah water really
noticeable during that fight that boss
fight
rob it yeah look at that she's USB in
that jerk's head all right that's
Horizon zero Dawn very exciting I feel
like people are still super hyped about
that when is this actually coming out
this is one of the ones I did February
28th 2017 very good my God perfect time
perfectly done uh okay just two weeks
after Valentine's Day there you go
something to get your loved one or
yourself if you're single okay let's
move on I'm getting tired man uh
we are down to the the the drags so drgs
seems unfair cuz a lot of this stuff
look good uh but let's wrap it up with
some voting put your hands out love it
okay what do you like what you didn't
like Crash Bandicoot's back it's
remastered no he didn't you don't like
remastered what's the 2016 Crash
Bandicoot look like I don't want a new
crash band play Uncharted man you oh
there you go all right um crash PS in
Skylanders I don't care about
Skylanders Skylanders let you draw on
pieces of paper and Skylanders appear I
bet that's not really what happens no I
think that's nice to promote that
creativity for children like a lot of
kids who are playing Skylanders already
yeah and Randolph Ramy who also likes
playing sky this Lego Star
Wars you can play the demo right now
just because K Ren got hit in the face
with a lightsaber thumbs up I always
feel like Lego Star Wars is out I
whenever they say new Lego Star Wars I'm
like wait isn't there already 15
confusing Star Wars overload Insomniac
or making a Spider-Man game was not soer
punch God knows what they're working on
sure yeah I liking some L right was am
Spider-Man's Spider-Man's costume
weird weird all right serene's on the
fence yeah we'll see about that H H
actually one we should actually talk
about before we leave last one to talk
about Call of Duty infinite Warfare they
showed it off it was the first time we'd
seen the campaign stuff like I consider
myself one of the most jaded Call of
Duty campaign people out there and I was
into this in a way that I haven't been
in a little while uh vote on it what do
we think Call of Duty I was paying
attention because I was still in shock
from the Final Fantasy 15 VR
announcement so I didn't see any of it h
so Peter what did you what did you think
of it uh I always love the spectacle of
the Call of Duty campaigns and this is
just full of that I mean this is just
over the top craziness and I'm in yeah I
mean you know in a dog fight sort of EV
Valkyrie style and then jumping out onto
a battle oning dudes just fling in space
and that's what's interesting is like
okay this is a new way to I mean you are
eventually just shooting other people in
the face you know in space in a
different type of warfare but it's you
know new types of cover new types of
strategies you know new types of
movement like you said using that tether
to get around like it makes you rethink
like oh what are the various ways that
we can you can use this like combat
environment which you don't know yet
yeah it's not like we've played this
game a thousand times yet yeah like I
typically don't play Call of Duty um
except for the campaign you know and I
feel like it's always so much more
creative than the multiplayer so I yeah
I think this looks pretty good Serene
what did you think of this I love the
Call of Duty campaigns it's like these
games have trained you to be a soldier
and I I know when I'm going into a
campaign that's exactly what I'm going
to get like you're the soldier you're
the captain you're the hero like you're
the leader and you're fighting this war
and it's going to be like so epic on
every level and now it's in space so
like they're taking it to the next level
and they're doing like so many cool
things that like everything you could
possibly do while fighting in space
they're doing it yeah there's a bunch of
like sorry I was say they're like roller
coasters right I mean sure they they
only last a short amount of time but wow
damn are they fun yeah look great as
well when you went indoors and then the
gravity kick back on again and like even
then they had stuff like that Shield
which showed you who was still alive and
where they were and you could like knock
people yeah there was one part where he
used a grenad to kill everyone oh it was
it was infrared and then he like flashed
up just to see which one of them was
still alive and then finished them off
um yeah like even the grenade stuff
looked interesting looked unique sort of
new takes on all the stuff there he is
and there's Earth there's Earth that
dude exploding in the foreground
beautiful yeah I don't know I think
we've got two great military first
person shooters coming out in 2016 I
think you're right yeah all right so
that's Call of Duty infinite Warfare uh
coming out they did do a uh Call of Duty
let's they did do a release day for that
as well I believe so let's get that in
there November 4th November
2016 all right that's it we're done you
forgot the Last Guardian release State I
don't care October 25th 25th there was
more than one got so clearly it wasn't
the boy was the guardian is he it's a
good point maybe the maybe they're a
team the last Guardians of the
Galaxy a long day huh it's been a long
day time for bed we're done that was uh
that was a bunch of press conferences
there today on Monday and yesterday on
Sunday E3 starts tomorrow morning oh
really yeah yeah the show floor opens
what have we been doing this whole time
I have no idea talking about Norman
Reedus's baby butt that's video games
can can we get that one more time nope
damn it nope don't have nightmares you
can go watch that on your own privacy of
your own home and nobody can say
anything to you but uh thank you so much
for watching gamespot's coverage of all
of these press press conferences we
really appreciate it but we are not done
yet we have two stages here at E3 this
one the Gamespot stage upstairs we have
the co-op stage downstairs which just
has a bunch of our friends hosting uh
some interesting conversations and then
up here we've got developers coming on
to talk about all the games that you
have seen many of the games that you
have seen uh David cage I think is on
tomorrow with Todd Harr and aoup couple
of others so looking forward to that uh
if you're watching on YouTube hit that
subscribe button if you're watching on
Twitch hit follow if you're watching on
Facebook well done and if you're
watching on Gamespot we love you all H
thank you so much for everyone for
putting together this show we will be
back live tomorrow morning starting noon
Pacific uh get some sleep and we'll see
you on the other side
[Music]
adios